[Music]
[Applause]
did we settle on a poll question before
we get to
the hall of famer yeah just to start i
put up the clippers question did they
have a good postseason i'm curious what
our la audience thinks
all right let me find out what chris
webber thinks about that the
member of the 2021 basketball hall of
fame former
analyst for tnt and of course fab five
at michigan
clippers have a good year chris
they had the best season in clipper
history
they left the league in threes and free
throw percentage they
maybe you know could have wanted to have
their best player they came down from o2
twice
i think they have the best season maybe
not the most exciting season when you
look at lob city or
or things like that but yeah and they
had the most successful season
definitely
what's chris paul's reputation as a
player
you know i think he's played so long and
he's had a few
been able to have a few reputations you
know at one time i think it was a
stubborn point guard uh that maybe
didn't get along
with his coaches at one time maybe it
was uh not the best teammate
and you know i think now what we see is
that
maybe all that was true because he was
trying to get to this point you know
because same thing could be said for
colby or others that had
you know uh ways about themselves that
was was winning first and you don't
understand it until you win a
championship and so
i think he's played long enough where
he's been able to uh kind of douse
those rumors and you know use those
rumors to his advantage and say well if
it was true it's only because i've been
trying to get here and look what i did
with this young team it's interesting
how a mid-range jumper
we just let you take the mid-range
jumper there's nothing sexy about it
and it doesn't impact you as much as hey
that guy just hit a three or that guy
dunked
chris it was like water torture it
wasn't a guillotine it was just
water torture just drip drip drip and
then you look up and you realize he
scored 31 of his 41 in the second half
how does that happen chris dan you know
you're a historian of the game you've
seen you've seen the great ones play
you you've seen alex english from vinny
johnson or agent badly
and think about what makes kd so great
what makes kd
great is that they're down four he's
shooting mid-range jumpers oh what makes
curry great
is he can hit mid-range jumpers and go
back door i think this is really um
i think this speaks more to coaches
following the leader
you know if you look at san antonio and
others maybe their teams aren't the best
but they play a mid-range game and what
do you have
the difference between these two teams
is now no middleton can
make three range shots and then this guy
right here i mean uh
chris paul is one of the best uh
paul george have a legitimate beef with
the media that um
the expectations we put in on on him or
what we expect from him come play up
time
i think he has a legitimate beef with uh
social media in the twitter verse uh you
know when i
i didn't i didn't necessarily hear his
rant and so if he's
if he said the media specifically i
think i think that's misguided
unless he's speaking certain you know
individuals in the media
but you know when you look at up to this
point he has the most points in the
playoffs
uh you know what he's done in the
playoffs i think he's had an excellent
play up i think he's
i think expectation is what really hurt
this clippers team because i really look
at them then
you tell me where they're good besides
besides
the two leaders you tell me what they're
good they don't have a big man and i
love zubaz
but he's really like a up on other teams
yeah whether they haven't got morris is
really good but when they have a guy
that can just go get his battery doesn't
have the same impact anymore
so talent-wise this team isn't better
than denver talent-wise this team is
nowhere near utah
and so um it's to me i think he's
uh caught he got caught up in
expectations and so
really taking the team to another level
over the playoffs
if they had kawhi who would know you
know who knows but i also wonder about
that as they move forward chris with
kawhi
is that knee going to be an issue the
rest of his career like
how much can you count on kawhi
so first i would say the mcl is not that
big of a
deal without i i say um not that i'm a
doctor but i've had some ncl
issues but i think his history whether
the arrest
of time management um things like that
you know i think that that that's a
concern but i don't think you can
you know i think that you kind of need
to do like uh having an aging
quarterback
kind of have somebody there for him to
train but they need a guy with a
different position
they have two of the best two-way
defenders but they're both six seven
both hands of ball they need someone
that has a different skill set that's
the best at their position but yeah i
would hurry up and give him some help
yeah i wondered about having a
legitimate point guard on this team
and how that could benefit the clippers
i i think i think it could help but i
think you need a legitimate scoring
point guard
and more importantly i think that they
need a big finisher
you know it doesn't have to be a center
but someone athletic someone that can
help the paint this is what i always
think about this team
they have great defense but you know how
hard they work outside on the perimeter
because they don't have any shot
blockers
so i mean if they have a shot blocker
they could conserve energy they could
get out of the fast break more things
like that so
i really think they need to address just
an athletic big
guy six nine six ten maybe he's the
center maybe he's not but
just someone that could keep up with the
pace of play that they have
hall of famer chris webber joining us on
the show you ever had an extend
a hyper-extended knee like what giannis
is trying to play through
yes yes uh it was scary because you know
uh it goes against all sense of balance
when when that happens that you
tend to think it is uh more serious than
it is but
i don't see if if he plays uh next game
i'd be surprised if he played the next
to i just um
things like that it takes a little bit
of a little bit of time not only to heal
but
the trust may be the scariest part yeah
just when you come down and you you just
see the
like what could have been i mean that
could have been you know career
threatening
man if he you know it doesn't seem like
he didn't have that body it was so
strong it was i mean it was one of those
things where i didn't want to watch the
replay just turn the sound up and
checked out what was going on but yeah
that was scary man i
i was listening to jamal mashburn on a
podcast the other day
and he was talking about when the
college players
were practicing against the dream team
and prac have you heard the story that
he was telling no okay
so you guys saw well he said we were
part of a group grant hill and some
other guys rodney rogers we saw larry
bird in the hotel
and then he said get some sleep young
fellas and then you guys went and
scrimmaged against them
and rodney rogers is talking smack to
larry bird larry's on the sidelines
just watching and rodney rogers all of a
sudden tugs on superman's cape what
happened after that
yeah well ronnie rogers is he's one of
the best
uh jerks that you'll meet and uh so
again we were all there playing against
our favorite player you know you got to
realize that
stockton and bobby hurley at grant hill
and jordan was all of our favorite
players individually
and you know they used to hide us in
these gyms were working out and we
didn't really know what was going on we
get to scrimmage these guys i mean we
really
you really beat them and uh the next day
or we're in a hotel or something you
know because they were really kind to us
they took us out to eat you know we got
to
get there be in their room and golf and
stare at them and he goes roger rogers
he's talking the stuff
that we were talking about and out of
the room you know our other one we're
talking like yeah magic didn't know what
to do and he
goes to bird right in his face he said
something like yeah
they made a jump shot since the 80s or
eight one of the years they probably won
a championship
84 and the next day man
there you go and uh the next day in
practice first we didn't score a buck
we didn't score a bucket that's when i
really knew it was the difference in the
nba in college because
the drills of denying i remember jordan
pulling up the shorts and denying that
you literally couldn't touch the ball
so bird uh i remember one time coming to
the corner
he pump fakes and rodney rogers goes by
he says welcome to the parachute club
three in his face you know after i don't
know if it was magic or someone
said something something like uh you
know that kind of reminds you of 84 a
little bit don't it and so
that was the best part about playing
against them is that they treated us
like their equals by talking trash to us
because that's that was the kids dream
come true but
no one told ronnie to start we weren't
trying to start a war at that time
i i loved who was the nicest guy on the
dream team to you guys
truthfully at the time i remember uh
scottie pippen took us to a dinner
but i remember patrick ewing and larry
bird always being together
and whenever they were together they
would crack on us
it was like we were there just you know
we just
crashed test dummies for chokes those
two were cool
took us to dinner but man they all they
all were great they pulled us to the
side
you know telling us things to work on
like uh that definitely was one of the
best
basketball experiences i've had uh i i
when people talked about how bird and
patrick ewing
developed this great relationship like
you never would have thought that
but you know patrick talks about it he
said you know we just
got along i don't you know it was just
we connected with each other
that that's not the pair that i would
have put together with that team
dance they didn't have a reality show
like uh
and uh my guy over there uh and philly
to buy his hair so yeah
they were kind of the odd couple but i
didn't you know because at the time we
were just fans of them so we it's like
wwf we only
at the time wrestling we only got what
you felt this and i thought patrick
was this mean guy is sweating all the
time
and i thought larry bird was just you
know country
and wouldn't talk to you and you know
you find out man maybe two of the
coolest guys
if uh the fab five had this name in
image and likeness like what
how different do you think it would have
been after your freshman year at
michigan
well i think even during our freshman
year michigan it would have been
you know incredible um it's crazy
because then i think yesterday someone
told me that
it was the 28th uh a year anniversary
and drafted at the same time
supreme court rule and the ncaa and it's
just it's really interesting because i
always think about johnny manziel
uh i'll tell you why like uh what what
if he never plays football again right
he you know he went to canada we know he
did all this sort of stuff and we know
he's famous for money and all that
let's just take any personal thought of
morale
right uh whether he got his place on his
own or whatever
he'll never be able to duplicate that
again
yeah and i think what people don't
realize is
it was always it was always a dumb
quagmire because
it had nothing to do with the ncaa you
know how many local car dealerships
would get more money by paying the
walk-on to come sit sign autographs at
that car dealership one person's gonna
buy a car
i mean period so you know you just cast
those numbers of a guy's value
and i just think that you know that's
the peak of your value
it's the peak and so to me you know
when i look at it i think you know if
our jersey so well if it was the highest
time of uh
uh highest admissions at the school that
we could sell black socks and hirachi's
and i'm pretty sure we would have done
well on our own selling t-shirts at ten
dollars a pop before the game
because you think about all the fake
t-shirts of us that went on before
what if we could have just sold those of
ourselves you know you know what i mean
so
i just think really it's the american
way to be able to use your name
and your likeness so to me it's just
common sense and i think we would
have done pretty well would you have
stayed an extra year
if you could have gotten paid as uh as
much as an nba rookie
that's a great question so let's
times were very different so uh i was 20
and i think at the time
uh no player had come out as a sophomore
since magic johnson was just 79 and
mom's like 18 years later so a big
difference
but yeah i mean i called it timeout we
lost the championship
um i wanted to stay there anyway and try
to win the championship you know you're
you're a kid you're young you figured
that you're going to live forever
and so for me in my situation well
most definitely i was 30 minutes from my
mother's cooking my family i'm the
oldest of five
yes i i would have and waited to take
that leap shaq left the year before as a
junior
so it made sense to me so yeah
definitely i think
uh you know i definitely would have to a
lot to think about i wouldn't have had
an excuse
and and you benefited uh jaylen rose
benefited juan howard benefited but you
know ray jackson and jimmy king
they didn't have pro careers and and and
they could have gotten paid as
members of the fab five and the way the
fab five
first of all you're right shout out to
ray and jimmy uh they're smart they
could have done it and we have rules
when we do things together
so we would have been more empowered
because everybody's average
went up because you got to pay random
the same so that's that's
definitely how we were but i want you to
think about a guy on our team like um
eric ryan he was the big ten shot
blocking leader before we got there came
there with us he was all right
to always follow to his car no we would
have got him things saying no
if you're gonna use me you know could
you use him next week we would empower
everybody to walk on that's what i'm
saying the way we were
team first the whole team would have
been in there and maybe you'll take less
whatever so no this empowers
everyone if i'm the best offensive
lineman and i'm going number one
i guarantee you all lyman could go sign
with me up here because now i can wield
my power for the team
for the guys you know so i think it's
awesome i think it's
stupid to celebrate because it's what it
should be you should use your own name
but at the same time i think it's
awesome for these young kids and these
individuals to
be able to use their name to be able to
focus on
you know so much pressure as a student
athlete
you still have to come through with the
grades depending on what program you go
to
uh you work just as hard as other
students but at the same time
you know it's cool to be a kid there on
campus depending on pizza and everything
but you know
it's a different world some of these uh
athletes have children some of them have
families that need them it's great to go
and send that back to us so
i look forward to seeing how uh the
supreme court they're ruling the ncaa
having to accept it
i look forward to seeing how it benefits
the lives of those student athletes
always great to check in with you chris
thanks for joining us as always
hey thanks that's uh chris webber c webb
member of the 2021 basketball hall of
fame class and former nba
analyst on tnt and the fab five at
michigan